Okay.
Um,
uh, I think I would have lost
my dad mind if she wasn't there.
My name is Dia Frampton.
I'm 31 years old and I am an
actress and a singer songwriter.
My name is [inaudible].
I am 31 and I am an actor.
I relationship reading my shit.
Yeah, we're in a relationship.
Go all right.
Here
we were at Busby's,
it was super packed and like the Red Sea,
I look towards the bar and I see Dhea
in amongst the crowd and she was double
fisting like alcohol.
I was pretty drunk.
I was with my friend Uri and I
just leaned over to her and said,
that guy's really hot.
He had really big hair at that time and
I grabbed one of his curls and I kind of
pulled on it and then he turned
around and I think I just said, hey,
I think I went away. It got scared and I
ran away. You said that really cool hair.
Oh, did I? Yeah, I just said, I
said, hey, and then I went away.
Are you saying I have cool hair and you
probably heard that a lot. I'm like, yeah.
Wow.
We went on a walk around the Silver
Lake Reservoir for our first date and we
stopped at Ellie.
Melanie got some coffee and we talked a
lot about our families and our past and
he told me so much about his family that
I actually went and wrote a song about
it.
She immediately made me feel
very comfortable in sharing, uh,
things that I struggle with my family
to the point where she actually made a
song about it.
Those are really beautiful song and
it made me rethink my whole situation.
It was almost like therapy,
like someone who really understood,
he paid for my drink, which made me really
happy. I don't remember. You did. Okay,
cool. I'm not going to lie. I'm a
bit old school. I'm from Utah and uh,
that's just how I was raised I guess.
So if I didn't pay for it,
you would have been like, it would've
been a little bit of a little for me.
It was, it just kind of all
these little things piled up.
All of a sudden it just felt like love.
It just happened.
Yeah,
she was performing with her band and by
the time I was already getting to know
her and how freaked out she gets before
she performs and just to know the
courage and the bravery to go up there
and to really be vulnerable with the
audience through your
ability to express already.
You made me find my more as an artist.
It just seemed to be this thing that
built up until it was just there.
It was the one I like played basketball.
I mean like a three pointer. No,
you're like, that's so
hot. No, no, it wasn't.
He feels uncomfortable with intimacy.
I almost feel like he didn't
see it a lot growing up.
Maybe I've been kind of taking the reins
with that and just being very vocal
about,
hey,
touch me or kiss me or kiss
me with sometimes and like
kiss me with your tongue.
Sure.
Used to be really negative in terms
of the competition and negative,
like if I didn't get
this thing or that thing,
it's because of me and my ability.
Just kind of confronting your own intimacy
and being open about that and more
vulnerable because I don't think you
saw that a lot growing up and not seeing
your own worth.
That was my main thing is your own
worth and how much she means to a lot of
people. Me and, yeah.
And you know, you don't give
yourself enough respect. Yeah.
There's always a lot going on,
trying to keep up with everything.
I always feel like time's running out,
I guess as a female musicians or I get
scared that I'm getting too old to,
you know,
barely be making rent and I always
am trying to stay positive I guess.
And they put you through a lot and I'll
put you through a lot to the intimacy.
That's something I've, I've
learned with, with dia.
I didn't really see much of it growing
up. Yeah. Like my, my, my mom is deaf,
um,
very limited language.
She has a tough time expressing herself
to me and my father very stoic from that
generation and they weren't
really intimate with each other,
so I didn't realize how
much that influenced me.
But I think the good thing about you
though is you're really open to working on
things,
which is you're the,
you're the first person to help recognize
that or not be afraid to be like,
you're like this.
My biggest vulnerability moment
was all my dad. I had a stroke. No,
my sister texted me and told me that
that isn't a hospital and it's pretty
serious and we are,
we were actually on the way
to palm springs when I got
the phone call and I told
her that we had to make a u turn and
just a lot of stuff in the closet that I
want to bring out from our father.
And um,
uh, I think I would have lost
my dad mind if she wasn't there.
And I'm just so torn between like yelling
at my dad and crying for my dad and
she's like, you know, struck
in my back and calming me down.
I had a little tour on the east coast and
he flew out and there were a lot of
people that came to the show is very,
very empty. It was a very empty room
was in Pennsylvania. And I just,
I actually started crying on stage cause
I felt almost embarrassed that the room
was so empty. He kind of saw me
like trying to hold it together.
I was trying to manage all my friends
who were the musicians and make sure they
were happy and pay them and get them
settled and then play shows and then also
will drive us to the next city.
Cause you did all that on your own
in the east coast.
I'm like that's so amazing.
No thank you.
Yeah I remember him,
hey were driving to the birthday party
in palm springs and all of a sudden he
got a phone call and we just
turned around,
started going towards the Long Beach.
I remember just telling him
that if anything happened
to his dad that I would be
there with him to take care of his mom.
I'm lucky I have a very large family.
I have five sisters that it would,
things go down,
we all kind of cup it and come
together and he doesn't have that.
And that's another thing that I told
him is that my family loves him and he,
he has five sisters too. Yeah. Now.
And they all love him.
And just kind of reminding him that
he's not dealing with this alone.
It's weird because I want
to be with him forever.
But the m word is just really,
it makes me feel like a kid,
but it makes me really scared.
We went on a break for about
six months and during that,
that time away I realized that
I could not live without him,
that whatever our future would be,
I would have to be with him.
And it wasn't this kind
of romantic revelation.
It was just fact.
I just knew that it was with Khalif.
I always think about this for some,
we always think about us on like a very,
you know,
like a nice little margin chic house
with these great couches and a fireplace.
And I could see,
uh,
the pool and the car outside and
we're just hanging out like we do now.
I always feel like
all marriages are going to fail and,
uh,
one of my friends get married. I just
secretly like there goes another one.
Oh God. Instead of seller
celebrating. Mm Love.
I just feel like they're in fort.
It's too terrifying.
I mean I definitely,
I think about it sometimes,
like I wanted something different from
when I knew from Mike. My parents,
like I want it to get it right.
Just be honest and true as much as I can.
And you're on my person.
I feel a little smaller when I leave you.
MMM.
Cause I feel very confident,
very loud, very supported. You
keep me always looking on the bright
side of things and in the present and
grateful for what I do have.
Warm.
Where you at?
Oh,
I guess I would say home too. I was going
to say comfort, but that's Kinda like,
it's job.
Even made it through the
questionnaire and wheelie walkers.
Marco wave.
No, he's getting, it's
gonna go
and you're left
you the sunflower.
I think you're to beat to match.
Then I'll be left in the dust
and the step by you to sunflower,
the sunflower,
you year your.